foreign
Eric joins us up next in Minneapolis
Eric welcome to the show
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help
um so I'm 19 and I just got my real
estate license early September and I
made some stupid decisions and I
invested a bunch of money about a year
and a half ago
and it was around 18
000 and now it's down to about 13 14 000
so pretty much over four thousand
dollars
um but I have no income and I have about
nine thousand dollars worth of debt and
normally I would just ride the roller
coaster but
um
well we just had a great conversation
about this Eric I hope you were
listening we did what did you invest in
was it single stocks
yeah it was I mean it was index funds
and single stocks and now
uh yeah like I said normally I I take
that back and this was like your entire
world this month I bet and this was your
life savings
yeah pretty much I I just have to ask
and I'm not doing this to poke fun I I
just want to know
did you get this advice from the Graham
did you get it from Tick Tock did
somebody tell you hey dude this is what
you need to take all your money and put
it here I'm just curious because I know
there's a lot of that out there right
now
no I don't I guess I don't really
remember where I I didn't even have
social media at the time but uh but
where did the idea come from to go hey
I've got 9 000 in debt I've got 18 in
the bank uh I'm gonna just let the debt
sit I'm gonna invest this all that's
what I want to know well so I actually
yeah so the debt came I didn't really
plan the show till probably three or
four months ago the debt came after all
the Investments I actually invest I got
student loans up in order to invest in
and then I thought Michelle and then I
realized I screwed up all right this is
you just got your your real estate
license I think you need to get any job
right now because it could be six months
to a year before you actually see
Commission on your first sale right
that's right
right and so we need income today and so
I'm gonna go find the best job that I
can with the skills that I have that
pays the most money so that I can create
a financial Foundation uh and as far as
the stocks go you might just need to
cash out because you need money right
now and so this 5 000 that you lost I'm
calling it a stupid tax and I'm gonna
learn to never do that again and only
invest into my retirement and have a
long-term mindset so that my butt
doesn't get taken from me when I lose
five thousand and you can take that
money and pay off his debt yeah because
it's going to be 13k that you're going
to receive right Eric
yeah but the and the other thing is I'm
living at home still so I it will last
me a long time so I feel like part of me
feels like if I just hang on to it and
be very well we're gonna work the baby
steps you're gonna work the baby steps
you're gonna cash out this stock you're
going to take 9k of the 13k you're gonna
pay off your debt and then you're gonna
put the next bit of money well you're
gonna keep a thousand as an emergency
fund then you're gonna pay off your debt
and then in the same day you're gonna
start putting towards three months of
expenses and we're gonna just walk up
the line and work these baby steps and
get a real job until Real Estate is
making you money that you can let go of
that job and do real estate full-time
and man once you you touch that hot
stove once it never happens again so I'm
glad you learned it early man we've
we've all done stupid with zeros on the
end and uh you'll look back at this and
laugh one day when you're a millionaire
and you follow these baby steps that's
right